H
EFFORT TO RALLY SUPPORT FOR THE
EMBATTLED GOVERNOR.
JOINING ME NOW IS KEVIN, LEADING
IN THE POLLS AS THE TOP DEMOCRAT
TO REPLACE GAVIN NEWSOM.
KEVIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING THE PROGRAM.
I HAVE BEEN CHECKING YOU OUT,
HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS.
I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW YOU FEEL
ABOUT THE DEMOCRAT ESTABLISHMENT
TRYING TO PUSH YOU OUT OF THE
WAY.
ACCORDING TO THEM, THIS IS A
REPUBLICAN RECALL.
LAST TIME I CHECKED YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S 100 PERCENT CORRECT.
I HAVE BEEN A DEMOCRAT SINCE I
REGISTERED AT 18.
HERE, LOOK, HERE IS THE THING.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS GONE SO
FAR TO THE LEFT I CALL MYSELF A
JFK STYLE DEMOCRAT QUI HAVE GOT
TO GO BACK TO THE COMMON SENSE
SOLUTIONS.
GAVIN NEWSOM IS RUNNING A
FEAR-MONGERING CAMPAIGN THAT'S
BECAUSE HE CAN'T STAND ON
POLICY.
HIS SHINY OBJECT TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT IS LARRY ELDER AND HE
CAN'T STAND ON ANYTHING THAT
MATTERS, WHICH IS HOMELESSNESS,
HOUSING, SCHOOLING, WATER,
FIRES, THE BIG ISSUES WE HAVE.
BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN A FAILURE.
THAT'S WHY I'M RUNNING.
>> Lawrence: YEAH.
SO TALK ABOUT YOUR DEMOCRAT
ESTABLISHMENT, WHY ARE THEY
GETTING INVOLVED IN THIS RACE
BECAUSE THAT'S ANTI-DEMOCRAT,
RIGHT?
GAVIN NEWSOM, THEY ARE SO
FEARFUL THAT I CAN'T EVEN GET A
DEMOCRATIC ATTORNEY TO REPRESENT
ME WHEN I NEED LEGAL HELP.
>> Lawrence: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> IF WE GO ON RECORD AS
SUPPORTING A REPUBLICAN RECALL
THEN WE CAN'T GET FUTURE
DEMOCRATIC CLIENTS.
I'M LIKE WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
IT'S A CALIFORNIA RECALL?
THE ESTABLISHMENT IS SO POWERFUL
THE MONEY IN MEDIA HAS JUST
CORRUPTED THE BUREAU SAYS.
AND I DON'T WANT TO BE TIN FOIL
HAT BUT MY EYES HAVE JUST BEEN
OPENED.
I'M GOING TO KEEP FIGHTING.
>> Lawrence: SO, KEVIN, I GOT TO
ASK YOU THIS.
WHY NOT SWITCH PARTIES OR BECOME
AN INDEPENDENT BECAUSE IT'S
CLEAR THAT YOUR PARTY LEADERS
DON'T WANT YOU THERE.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
I BELIEVE THAT VOTER DETERMINE
ELECTIONS.
AND I HAVE SOME PROGRESSIVES
PRIORITIES THAT I VERY MUCH
STAND FOR.
FOR EXAMPLE, I THINK WE SHOULD
PAY ADULTS IN POVERTY $2,000 A
MONTH TO GO TO FUTURE SCHOOLS.
TO GET A FINANCIAL EDUCATION.
LEARN A CAREER.
SO WE CAN GET THEM OFF OF
WELFARE AND OFF THE MEDI CAL AND
BREAK CYCLE OF POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS.
SLIGHTLY MORE LEFT.
I CALL MYSELF JFK STYLE BECAUSE
I BELIEVE I'M 51-49 I'M SO THE
MIDDLE I WANT CALIFORNIAN
SOLUTIONS.
>> Lawrence: YOU DON'T SOUND
MUCH LIKE A DEMOCRAT.
YOU SOUND LIKE AN AVERAGE DAY
REPUBLICAN.
MODERATE.
I HAVE READ YOUR STANCE ON
CRIME.
AND YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN
DEFUNDING THE POLICE AND ALL
THAT.
I'M GOING TO BE FOLLOWING THIS
RACE, BROTHER.
AND EVEN IF YOU DON'T WIN IT, I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOU MORE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
THE SHOW.
>> THANKS